let's see the they are offshooted
and uh
we see
knight f3
change of openings why not
and now g3 i'm expecting look at d5 on
the board
ratey
yes bishop g2
g6 castle bishop g7
it's clear that i think magnus wants to
have a long game and play it out and try
to take advantage of the fact that he's
extra
three minutes on the clock
so to give as many difficulties
and we shouldn't forget that actually i
think it will be a match the world
championship match in november
which it's not only that
napo is a great player and it has a very
challenging style for magnus but also
he's an exceptional good rapid and blitz
player
and this makes a huge difference
compared to the previous challengers
because with kariyaki and i think it was
pretty clear for magnus that he's going
to be the favorite in a rapid and
shortening time control and so the
players are marking out their territory
they are now pawns on d4 and c4 so a5
that this is a very common response and
now probably expecting moves like knight
to two
but of course sometimes you also have to
think after all if you have extra three
minutes
yeah exactly
also yeah
why not uh or knight c3 is another move
yeah nice fd2 e3 these are all
possibilities that have been played
before yeah but here the main idea i
think for magnus to choose a move where
he believes that he can hold and hold
the tension keep the tension
try to complicate matters as much as
possible and simply to play long long
long
knight c3 on the board okay
so far the players are playing fast more
or less one minute each
which they spend which favors white
it does favor white so i'm expecting
black to trade off the knights
it seems to me quite
quite logical option to exchange and
then play bishop e4 to
to have the knight pinned because black
would be happy if he can exchange the
white square bishop this is why bishop
h3 might be a possible move and
continuation in order to try to move
knight d2 without exchanging divide
square bishop
and
magnus pushing forward and i'm just
looking at the most popular move and
that's to play rook fc one this is
what's on the board on the board and the
whole point is that uh once black
develops the knight to d7 then there
will be a trade no there will be a trade
of pawns first okay so
so now a
a line is given away by black
queen b6 attacking the b3 pawn right now
so queen b2 what i'm expecting
[Music]
or
maybe
i don't think he wants to go an id too
i have doubts no because that's uh
a trade yeah and the position becomes
more simple and of course
life would be captured and knight d7
simply developed the position
so after queen b6 white should be
solving his uh
questions maybe rook a3 that's an
optional move
rook a3 is nice
yeah okay s3 is possible
though still white needs time to be able
to move away with his
knight on f3
other moves could potentially be move
the queen away
well uh queen d1 is possible but
on e2 it stands very well so you don't
really want to move away i think with
the queen
and after queen
also knight a6 is possible to reach out
to b4 possibly
uh okay we have b4 i like b4 so b4 was
it possible to take space yeah
but now i'm expecting pawn takes pawn
yeah because black white wants to go c5
that's a serious threat yeah to get the
space advantage so probably d takes c4
but no he doesn't play at 97.
oh
well i would be playing c5 in a
heartbeat
bishop f1 for example i would consider
bishop f1 or also bishop h3 attacking
the d7 knight and freeing up my knight
from f3 going to d2 bishop h3 is is nice
i like it
but i i must admit
my instinct to push forward with the
pawns is too strong
c5
it seems like magnus is really in the
mood that okay he wants to just push his
phones later
and gain space advantage black goes back
queen b8 queen a2
c5
queen b8
so let's see if he's going to go queen
a2 or he just comes back with his rook
to a3 let's say queen a2 on the board
and now bishop takes knight followed by
bishop
very energetic typical nepo i think he
doesn't want to stay passive he wants
action he wants to react immediately but
i tell you one thing that i know about
these type of positions is that
this
kind of strike is only dangerous in the
middle game and it's only dangerous if
you have some weaknesses around your
king and uh otherwise you just ignore it
but there is a threat right this night
paul takes pawn followed by
but i want to take the bishop
okay okay i don't want to fall into the
trick what do you want to show play
against me knight c5 right yes
yeah he read me like a book
but then of course black can go knight
e5 bishop would go to e2
um it's not so obvious that black will
have enough uh play because this rook on
a7 it gives a
pressure over black and one day when
white is able to play b5 and break
through or just push his phone all the
way to b6 it can give great
challenge for black and the difficulties
this is this is really strategically
almost lost
actually so actually
after pawn comes to b5 and b6 you know
it's really terrible kind of position
and uh
i feel that with white
space you called it so now we're going
to expect after pawn takes pawn well but
there's an option to play c4 b4 and
knight c5 but then let's say bishop goes
here and after knight c5 bishop b4 would
be the move yeah pins the rook and black
can be in trouble just in a second
so b5 there is a lot of pressure put on
napogniachi by magnus
and he has five minutes and 24 seconds
while napo has only four minutes
and uh
seven seconds what did he play he pushed
e4 so let's see if magnus will push
bishop g4 first and trying to provoke
the knight goal
we were just looking and what a huge
advantage for white i believe because
there's not much of a hunter chance and
look just within a second he just when
he got the chance to play c5 before b5
and puts yeah sorry i was really excited
that because i mean this is just i mean
it's it's in the books
that's uh you don't close up the
position like this and it's also e5 is
not enough unless you have something
tangible against the king very difficult
so now it's now it's lost well yeah i
mean there is a very good chance that
it's objectively lost because b takes e6
already has threat so he has nothing
better it seems like he has to give up
an exchange which is not funny at all
yeah
maybe he missed this
um
i think he just strategically
missed this option that b4 b5 sometimes
there is simply positional blunders yeah
you're not in time with your counter
chances and this is what happens here i
think with black yeah knight a6 was an
opportunity
takes takes and let's see if b6 is the
move i think
though b7 is also very interesting try
and play queen ace queen a6 maybe this
is the simplest by the way yeah
because uh black goes away and then
maybe b6
well it's not clear of course whether he
should be playing rook b7 or just
playing bc so b6 you can just simply go
bishop takes knight afterwards and
there's no actually magnus plays very
well today i but i i really feel that
napomnerchie was a bit careless at
moments he allowed c5 he didn't need to
do that
and then
he
closed down the center for
yes but i think in that point you can
see also in napo's phase that he's
very unhappy with himself with his
decisions what he did
just in the last few moves
and
you can see how focused and concentrated
magnus is and he knows that here is his
chance and he knows that he has to win
this game but still
knows that he can spend a little time
and make the decision this is also a
very crucial moment in this game yeah
should i go simplifying with rook b7
queen a6 is that the winning
end game
or will b6 be the move and that's the
better
i think
he's going to get b6 i don't know if
he's no he's taking it he's taking it
yeah he's taking it uh
probably because
this way there is no
any tricks what black can do and after
taking the c6 even if he's not going to
be cleaning so fast if he takes the c6
his bishop is going to be playing bishop
d1 bishop b3 and he's going to capture
some more bones
but let's see there
napo is going to take his queen whether
c7 or b8
i think uh quincy seven
because actually after queen c7 you're
allowed
b6 but b6 you can go queen b8 and then
and then bishop d6 trying to save
yourself we're on the verge of a move
queen takes pawn queen takes pawn and
the problem is the d5 pawn is going to
be falling off this is the main problem
so now the question is is he going to be
exchanging the queens and just grab the
bone with bishop d1 is it going to be a
win for white
i mean
there is a good chance that it is
winning but of course and this is what
we are heading to and he's just going
for the safe thing he doesn't want to
give any chance not even the slightest
idea that he can be tricked or anything
and this game should be this end game
should be when white
and g5
okay g4 g4 sorry king f6 h4
very straightforward uh
very with very secure hand as you say in
hungarian i don't know if you say it in
english but uh
stable i think stable hand
and uh maybe maybe not maybe that's not
the right
bishop
bishop d8
so now the question is whether is going
to be provide the best move to play h5
for example
and then after takes take on f5 takes
and even f3
this is possible i think it should be
winning but of course when we talk and
he went h5 yes
and now
i mean
actually it's not even that after takes
takes takes i think white will just go
bishop g8 trying to go bishop h7 and
once black goes back
the players have uh yeah this is uh
making a lot of moves yeah bishop e4 so
now white has three past pawns
and
now the question is whether black is
going to be capturing
the f pawn and trying to save himself
which i don't think there is too much
practical chance for black either way
but maybe kind of keep those two past
pawns on the board
it means that black has to be moving
back then king g3 and immediately white
is capturing
already one of the points okay
we have it on the board yeah this is on
the board bishop
h5 a5 actually it was a very good try by
magnus because now the problem is that
even this position
with
if the d4 pawn would not exist it's also
winning because there is three
empty
files between the two pawns and that's a
win okay but let's see what how he did
he went b6
which i don't understand at all
so his idea is just to round up all the
pawns yeah he just wants to keep three
and that's it
causes a resignation from the pognyacci
and magnus once again is triumphant in
the armageddon